I think we're getting better but I think
athletes have been looked at as race
horses I don't even think there's kids
out there that understand what recovery
is we show up to a college campus and
it's like here's the weight room here's
the locker room here's the gym there's
the frat house and there's the bar what
about my mental health how about when
things get really low for me where do I
go then who's going to kind of catch me
when I'm struggling we don't do enough
of that right and to even discuss or
bring up the topic of Mental Health is
to kind of imply weakness and you're not
here to be weak you're here to be strong
so if you're struggling keep it to
yourself and you know buck up but most
people show up with mental health yeah
of course what kid isn't going to show
up to college campus and have some type
of trauma something that he's going to
need help with but we have to wait to
Rock Bottom